thank you dear friends it's so nice to
see you let's get right to it
did you notice that executing the same
actions in different order can often
leads to different results even if we
take very very correct actions that
normally get us to beer or some other
wonderful results and do that in the
wrong order we can get into a disaster
how often have we heard our [ __ ] I
should have done that first the famous
thing I need a spatial applies in the
software development because as we all
know premature optimization and what is
premature where is this point it is
pretty hard to predict sometimes so what
we're going to do today is we're going
to talk about some not so obvious
aspects of building the distributed
system of micro services in Python and
as well as in other languages without
failing much because I know that's like
yes if if you are full-time employees
getting fired is pretty hard if you're
freelancers gets easier fortunately we
have now this whole micro service hype
makes things much easier you can fail in
so many ways so getting fired this is
really getting there so I will be also
sarcastic sometimes so if you recognize
yourself it's not you I'm not I don't
mean anyone I mean myself in the first
place because I went through this whole
thing and let's start simple we start
with a stage zero before even the whole
micro service thing starts imagine that
the big boss is calling you hey we have
to talk you think am I already fired
what's happening no you're not
he says it's time I was thinking I was
reading report it's time that we go
microservices at this point you might
think hey but sir we just hear the
Dressler saloon we accept booking
something on the phone anyway like what
are we going to split into micro
services don't do that don't do that
that's humiliating the boss he perhaps
read so many Gartner reports about
success stories he was thinking how he
will brag in the bar with his boss
friends.i hey-oh
micro-services now what do you have and
you offer him some Django thing no let
just do what he wants because otherwise
if you don't then you failed the stage
of the euro you will not even get that
job as a freelancer is particularly
relevant and now you think I'm talking a
bit extreme maybe but I have a real-life
case I worked for one big and famous
company which will I will obviously not
name they hired me to fix their
architecture and when I presented my
first draft they said all right but we
are a micro services so what micro
services is that a requirement they say
of course I mean looking to the future
now she's supposed to be an expert so
good well should understand that micro
services are not so much a tech solution
as an HR solution when you have
thousands of people and they have to
cooperate on the same project
efficiently that's a very good way to go
or if the Lord is has such a difficult
nature but you guys you have like one
requests per second big time they were
disappointed we are hiring an expert and
you're offering us a monolith so let's
just agree micro services take it as
granted it's hype they will come
don't resist it accept it and start
forming you're happy and motivated team
that is just easier to jump right into
that right into the immigration how
would you normally do such a big new
beginning you would perhaps read a book
and there are many good books you have a
good selection also of the cloud
container patterns available now
published everywhere even for free but
the book I mean the book is boring who
reads a book it's sound 19 for God's
sake we have Google Google is a new book
Google is all we need why would you read
500 pages in advance your team will be
so upset so if the team wants to just
prototype you know freedom of choice and
the freedom is a basic human right they
will be upset if you don't let them
prototyping you might lose your job so
don't do that
let them prototype because Google driven
development is actually not that bad
it's not as bad as Stack Overflow driven
development who knows the difference
difference is that Stack Overflow is
when things are
fire so if it's Google they are sort of
planning it in advance right now let's
go a bit more serious now let's go
deeper down to the stack stack you have
to design it from scratch and here to be
correct I have to say stack sip because
we have a new fancy polyglot
infrastructure we have many languages
and it's not just about the languages
because every language has on stack
every language has on tools on build
process and now we have many of this
wonderful you know when you push Python
code you perhaps do pilings you perhaps
run tests you package it somehow flake
it's whatever build the docker image
that's one way of doing it now imagine
the next thing you have is Java you'll
get to know me even the beauty of maven
or ant you will pack things differently
some jars so worse or whatever they're
using and now imagine we have front-end
as well on the stack we have JavaScript
wow you would have to minimize it add
shims can catalyze stuff Babel other
things a wonderful life and then if it's
really really front and and the webpack
goop grunts oh that is so much fun I
have a perfect illustration for this I
took from the GS Congress in Munich it
says there are milk products that last
longer than some JavaScript frameworks
that totally reflects the situation of
the front-end these days so yeah your
stack will look perhaps like that and
just share it with the ops ops will be
so happy to see it they either jump out
of the window or throw you out of the
door so get prepared
get your team with you so that it won't
be you but of course of course you can
always say it's better than an old ugly
monolith this nasty Jenga tower standing
out there ready to fail we're going to
fix this with microservices and it will
be made more elegant there is a surprise
waiting for you because if you if you
migrate from here to micro-services 90%
of cases you'll get many little junket
hours instead of one big
always its own stack on with its own box
and with own hacks to keep it somehow
stable and alive you know now imagine
that the registry have micro teams right
imagine there are just one or two people
working on each Jenga tower it's a good
thing cannot get fired because they
depend on you heavily right now so they
will probably not just not fire you so
the smart voice would probably vaccinate
you against everything in this world
because their business depends on every
every little piece of this and you're
basically and replaceable I love it as a
result what I call it is an epic slew of
technology imagine the front end is
unreacted statistics is an R and then
you have some admin side HP legacy you
have accounting made in Java you have to
maintain that whole thing somehow and
this components they they bark some
components meow and another components
role and sorry I forgot the fish fish is
important but it just writes logs so can
keep silent now imagine how can you
possibly manage this whole thing how can
you keep this component sane and well
for keeping it saying we are going to
the next chapter even deeper even more
concrete we are going to repeat some
wisdom of a bigger companies that did it
in the past already imagine the new team
member comes and says I don't care it's
all in Python I want my new fancy micro
service in JavaScript what you have to
do we were not to offend him or her
should be polite and you just use the
wisdom of Netflix Netflix had this issue
they had the whole thing done in Java it
worked perfectly until they hit certain
architectural limits so they had to
split into micro services which were
Java micro services and then they grew
grew grew and eventually they had to
deal with other languages as well so
they developed a very very smart
strategy that works for them at the
beginning they said of course at Netflix
you're very welcome to pick any language
you like you have a total freedom in
doing that but just just in case just in
case that language you'll pick will be
Java you'll get the failover you'll get
the discovery you'll get logs you'll get
monitoring all for free automatically
but if it's not Java well you're very
welcome to implement it in your language
of choice and at this point most of the
developer said maybe Java is not that
bad option what I wanted to say is that
at the first stage all right let's say
you have to split your monolith into
many components but that doesn't mean
you need to have that zoo right away you
can still stick with one or maybe two
platforms that will be well tested that
will have a well-defined process on the
up side of building things and testing
things and on deploying things so it
costs a lot especially on that in the
beginning to integrate every new process
in your architecture so if you can avoid
it just avoid it at the beginning and
you can pick just one reliable well
known language such as Java and work
with that kidding kidding
NORs so let's say we take Python we need
still to decide on the exact tools that
we are using in Python to write micro
services and here I'm just going to
quickly jump over the most popular
framework choices that we have let's
start with Django that's not a joke if
you're damn good in Django you can write
a microservice in Django
I know people who did that it feels to
me like going grocery shopping on a
truck nonetheless nonetheless yes you
can do that steel because Django is
still like this very very flexible
plug-in architecture which you can
customize we can throw use the things
out and you have wonderful pieces like
an admin panel there automatically but
the problem is that if you take Django
by default it has so many components so
if you think of that actually each
component could be a separate
microservice so it doesn't really make
much sense to use Django as it's shipped
to you it only makes sense if you cut
things you don't need out then it's fine
and speed wise I mean we don't have to
discuss Django we all know its
advantages and disadvantages but it is
still doable so here many would suggest
flask flask
everyone loves flask basket so
minimalistic it's fit so well the whole
idea the whole concept of micro-services
because it does just one little thing
and it does it right
I like flask and flask is is okay it's
not the most fast web framework but it's
a comfy one what I like and flask is a
synchronous networking and this is
particularly useful micro-services
because when you have a chain of
requests from one micro service to
another and they are blocking and one
thing fails and the whole chain is
blocked and does not serve more requests
because potentially I know it gets out
of the workers in the pool that's bad
it's not cool so I strongly prefer and
suggest you to use the synchronous tools
so that you are not blocked if one of
the components is blocked and you don't
have a limited amount of slots of the
parallel requests that you can process
at one point of time so there is a
solution there is squirt quiet is the
replica flask is just a synchronous copy
of last let's say I didn't check it out
in production I just know it exists I
played with it it has a very same API as
flask does I think they are developing
it further now but it's a good option
nonetheless as I said I didn't check it
in production flask I did so if you were
a flask person and I know
flask is a much better framework because
it has a cooler logon and its
minimalistic it's like 500 minimum thing
does all you need looks fancy for those
who do not need to compensate you know
with a big scale totally love flask now
I'm just going to quickly talk about
other options there there is hug who
knows hug hug is great hug is based on
Falken Falken
they say by free by the benchmarks that
Falcon is the fastest web framework in
python by amounts of requests per second
it can handle Falcon wins it's
synchronous but it's very fast and then
hug is a sort of abstraction over the
simplifies building API it's like Django
rests for Falcon makes developing
restful endpoints very easy
generates you the common line interface
right away because remember your micro
service is not necessarily they have to
communicate over HTTP it could be that
it's very useful if you have something
like Amazon CLI available right away
you create a normal restful endpoints
you have a console interface
automatically that's pretty handy I use
tagging production that's a great job
then there is tornado tornado is fifteen
year old now as far as I remember it's
super stable it's synchronous it's well
tested will document it it's like more
more the older version of a sinkhole
let's say that supports Python 2 as well
which for some cases because usually
when you come to the project that wants
an architecture upgrade the chances are
that they have a lot of components
written in Python 2 so with tornado you
can have a fancy synchronous
communication right away since 2.6 they
sort of assimilate the yield from or
async/await thing with just normal
Python generators so you can use yield
you can use yield with Python 2 and it
just works very similar to the way I
think i/o does I'm not putting a single
on slide because that is so obvious like
that's the default thing you'd go with a
HTTP and they think I oh that's now the
default way to go now the project grows
and thanks to Python of course at some
stage we hit the point as Netflix did
where we cannot resist getting new
languages and new stacks anymore so what
can we do then then we should use the
container patterns and there are books
published there articles published and
also many many videos on YouTube about
that I'll describe three most popular
patterns that are used in that I checked
personally let's start with a sidecar
sidecar is sort of extra container that
he puts next to your main container that
would enhance it to be more precise here
is how it looks like imagine that you
have a main container which is a web
server and your sidecar container is the
log saving application why would you
need to separate it you you might ask
you can have your main application and
something like a century agent that
collects your looks or cabaña or
whatever
the trick is that every web server even
super old one in Super legacy one can
write logs to the hard drive and not
every old framework has Center
integration so we go a bit another way
and we say let's just assume every app
can write logs to the hard drive and we
take another container that would pick
logs from the hard drive and send it to
whatever cloud aggregation system this
way we separate totally the
responsibilities of these two we say
that the web server should just do the
web related job and save logs as it can
and it's a job of the sidecar container
to pick this lock ups process do the
whole routine find the right cluster to
submit it this sort of work this is the
first pattern that you can use and the
second one is ambassador it's a very
similar concept sort of a big important
fella that you have to speak to instead
of speaking to some even bigger entity
this is especially useful when you are
dealing with some remote resources like
a database or a Redis cluster ambassador
will hide it
for you ambassador resides on your
localhost it runs next to your main
container and you only communicate with
the Ambassador it simplifies a lot
because in your super huge application
you perhaps have a super huge Redis
cluster that every component that speaks
to has to maintain e-way they need the
IP or dns and if it's failing then you
need a new root so this is all job of
the ambassador and the master is always
on localhost the same port so if
anything fails it's a job of an
ambassador to get the new root find
maybe do some graceful degradation in
this case or caching things as well can
be done on the Ambassador level so this
is also a pretty common pattern very
useful when you're writing big big
distributed systems it is particularly
useful because as I already mentioned
when the new language comes in it does
not affect the main container you can
have a main container in Java and you
can have your ambassador in
any other language they communicate over
standard protocol standard ports they
are totally running independently
now finally the adapter the adapter
looks like like an ambassador but the
reverse ambassador if the ambassador
pattern represents an application your
main application with a simplified view
of the outside world outside cluster
then the adapter does the reverse it
simplifies the view for the outside
world of your application to give you an
example imagine the monitoring case like
perhaps we want to have a health check
on our main application and different
frameworks different applications serve
from different protocols they have
different ways to check if the app is
alive or it's down some would provide
you a URL like slash Health's or
whatever some would write in a file in
UNIX that would say file is there then
I'm up and some would just not do
anything you would have to do PS outs
and check if the product process is
running in the UNIX machine so we can
use adapter to help the outside
centralized monitoring system to get the
status of every component because we
will ship this monitoring adapter next
to our main application and the adapter
will know how to check if the main
application is dead or alive it would
know if it should check a file or check
a URL and so then the external the
external part the monitoring system
would just use the same way to ask the
adapter if the system is running or not
this way you can also scale framework
independent and you can keep the same
monitoring system on a very very very
diverse zoo now quickly going to the
functionality after we know the patterns
as we already discussed micro service
usually has some business logic like the
main thing that it usually does either
serving some crude operations on the
database or doing some monitoring or
something else and there are always
communication functions which are
repetitive across many different
projects it makes sense now to take
these communication functions and put up
in a sidecar that
patterns already described to you
because they are very repetitive they do
this failover and discovery and graceful
degradation thing it looks much more
elegant like that but we still have one
problem now we loaded all of the
functionality of network functions to
the sidecar however nonetheless how
should different application find each
other you packed it into sidecar but
what exactly is the sidecar doing how is
the network communication and discovery
happening you need to communicate not
only with the database your components
perhaps also need to communicate with
each other and how exactly can this be
done elegantly you can of course would
ambassador for each service but you know
it will quickly get insane you can you
can break things and lose your job so
you need a better way of establishing
communications not just with a big Redis
cluster but also with the components
talking to each other like small dots
and here we can finally introduce the
concept of a service mesh it's a new
step it's yeah it's a bit centralized
it's a centralized component that keeps
keeps track of which service is doing
what's and available where and the idea
is it's that communication between our
little our little services they do not
communicate only over service mesh they
just use service mesh to find where are
other components located they still
communicate directly so this is like DNS
on steroids basically you can say I can
just use DNS at the beginning but DNS
depends on caching and in such an
architecture you cannot afford caching
too much because if a system fails you
need a very very quick replacement for a
failed system and that's exactly what
service mesh does so you can think of it
just as a better DNS system and to be
more precise what exactly is doing I
have a list here like you normally of
Lodz
tasks like routing access control it's
another big thing that I'm not
discussing right now but when you
communicate with in micro services you
need to decide on the common way how if
you encrypt the data how exactly how do
you decide if one service is allowed to
ask another service of a particular
operation then there is always a context
of are you asking one micro service to
another on behalf of user or you just
need some meta information all of these
little things you have to do
repetitively in every new micro service
you bringing into your architecture and
not to do that you upload this
repetitive tasks to the sidecar and the
service meshes just maintaining the
lists something like the access control
list routing list task list and so on
good finally I want also to say a few
words about the failover people say
graceful degradation and short
circuiting there are many fancy ways of
saying how would you elegantly tell your
users I'm down it's way more easy to
bring the system down when you have many
little services because it's a chain if
one element of a chain fails
I mean if instead of showing error 500
you are showing a message I'm sorry
we're currently not working it's more
elegant but it's not good so instead of
instead of doing putting effort in the
short circuiting and failover I would
strongly suggest you to put your effort
in better logging and better tracing
there is an open try standard that was
developed especially for this case when
you have a big system and it's it's hard
to it's hard to debug it it's hard to
trace where exactly did the request fail
instead of putting your effort into
excuses I'm sorry we couldn't do it
trace it log it make a have a system we
have here sponsors what was the data dog
people like they do it I use data dog
for that I'm not advertising them but
also New Relic does it invest your time
they are built a reliable system where
you can easily trace every requests and
every time you can say if something
fails it was Fault of this component
because without this
you will do it is certainly eventually
lose your job thank you for attention
and I wish you a very nice zoo of your
micro-services
[Applause]
Thank You intern for this refreshing
talk and we now have time for questions
so we have microphones on the side or I
can also move okay so in the meantime
while they get inspired I wanted to go
back to your recommendation on basically
the frameworks and there has been quite
some articles about why and talks about
why frameworks are can also constrain
you a lot especially when you want to
iterate over your products or let's say
add new features because they basically
fix a way the business logic is defined
so would you have also some
recommendations where on maybe just
smaller libraries or how you how you
would approach that if basically writing
is not an option yes of course well one
trends is things like lambda functions
on AWS many people do it many people do
it successfully there is basically no
framework that's just a function as long
as it's simple it works however if you
are not so much afraid of leaving that
project and you think that there should
be another person replacing you
eventually frameworks are like like a
common patterns that other developer
knows if I leave a project and they tell
you it's just the Django rest endpoints
and you can find right away it's
supposed handler it's a get handler and
you can just continue working right away
if you do a customized system obviously
it's harder for new people to get into
it on another hand there is no work you
love using a framework especially in
micro services because even tornado it's
quite minimalistic nonetheless it has
also as Jenga does many batteries
included like CSRF protection and so on
which you normally would not need in
microservices so your rights it's always
a trade-off when you pick a framework
you make things simpler for yourself and
also for people who will be working on
the project after you if you do it
yourself you usually can tailor it
better you maybe can do it
even more efficient but there will be
difficulty in maintaining it when it
grows and then don't forget the testing
you would perhaps test things that be
differently when you writes
micro-services because it's not so much
about unit tests in micro-services as
about integration and acceptance tests
you need to check the whole chain not
just one thing and here testing
frameworks that act predictably is
sometimes your simpler than testing
custom code that is not so predictable
for others not for you for others that
test their components speaking to your
component so yeah but there is no black
and white answer thank you thank you the
presentation as for father said
discussed in his blog post about micro
services there is eNOS for this error
propagation a synchronous communication
and the problem is that when you add
micro services to your system
probability of going down actually
increases because we with with each
micro service that can go down so the
solution is a synchronous communication
between micro services it'ld and it may
be HTTP or anything else what did you
try to discuss it what can you tell
about about switching to a synchronous
communication if you mean just switching
from synchronous HTTP to as synchronous
HTTP it will not change much the
protocol is the same it's just what I
meant at least in my part was that the
framework that the webserver behaves
differently instead of blocking one
worker doing one requests you have the
i/o loop that would handle that requests
as soon as it's not hitting any i/o
boundaries and if you hit on your
boundaries which you always do in micro
services because you're always waiting
for either a database or cache or
another micro service it can serve other
requests as well
that is what I meant with a synchronous
communication I do not see the effect of
this on the error tracing because the
protocol is the same it's silly HTTP on
as a client you should
in the best case not even notice it is
asynchronous so it's synchronous
regarding the error tracing yeah and
again I didn't mean error tracing on the
client level like HTTP error codes like
error five hundreds or whatever else as
I meant error tracing inside the
application because you your request is
passing through so many systems it's
hard to to match by time for instance
that's a typical first step that
developers do when something fails they
try to find logs on that point of time
but it is going so fast that you perhaps
will have hard time figuring out because
at exactly the same time in many many
services many many things could have
happened at the same time stamp so it's
harder to do this chaotic time based
debugging and you need more centralized
tool that collects all logs and that
somehow is marking every request with
some headers which which are then passed
around from one micro service to another
so that you can trace it from the entry
point to the exit point what exactly
happened where that is what I meant with
error handling
sure that's correct but I was asking
more about dealing with unavailable
services for example what do you do when
you issue an a request to a micro
service that should be there but it's
not there
it may be it's not there for like 10
seconds and the question is will your
system be failing for this 10 seconds or
will your system very silent and be able
to recover of course we will have to
stop here now so I would suggest you to
continue that during the small break we
have the let's fix Anton once more
please and then we have a break
you